[Musique]
marie emménagent dans son nouvel
appartement quelques jours elle se
réveille à cri piqûre
horreur les punaises denis lavant
thirith durant son sommeil
aussitôt l avis son propriétaire comme
le veut la loi le propriétaire découvre
que marie a acheté un mac lot
d'occasions dans les petites annonces
il est certain que c'est elle qui a
amené les punaises que ce soit vrai ou
pas selon la loi le propriétaire doit
d'offrir un logement salubre et assumer
seule le coût des traitements
par contre après la décontamination
il peut présenter une demande de
dommages-intérêts à marie il devra
prouver à la régie du logement que les
punaises sont arrivés avec marie ce qui
est difficile à faire
le fin mot de l'histoire même si c'est
d'un locataire qui les invite c'est au
propriétaire de chasser les parasites